[Music]
ever since the first rumors people have
had a lot of mixed feelings about Teen
Titans go to the movies from shocking
reviews to really surprise in cameos and
Nicolas Cage's dream come true this is
the untold truth about this highly
expected DCU movie don't forget to hit
that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out the story behind
Teen Titans go to the movies Deadpool
for kids that's how one of the reviews
actually described the Teen Titans go
movie it's like Deadpool but for kids
meaning the movie really does just mock
the entire DC world which is pretty
funny considering it got mocked for even
being in the DC world all these years
it's payback time of course the movie
still keeps the original Teen Titans go
sense of humor but it appears to be that
this is only enhanced in the actual
movie it comes with plenty of meta jokes
reserved for DC you fans only which
really does make it comparable to the
beloved Deadpool franchise the movie
even has a running Deadpool reference
but you'll have to watch to know what
actually happens of course you won't see
Brian Reynolds parading around anywhere
in this movie and there won't be a lot
of jokes adults can appreciate but there
will be a lot of nostalgic moments kids
are just too young to remember or
appreciate in fact the meta jokes and
brilliant one-liners really add on to
the plot that is rather simple but
effective talking about meta what all
these little superheroes are doing is
trying to convince a Hollywood director
that they really deserve their own movie
because almost every superhero has it
too that's the entire plot and it's
absolutely amazing because it's true
Emmy nominations but if you're thinking
that there is no way Teen Titans go to
the movies can even be remotely
successful you're wrong the actual show
maybe hasn't succeeded in attracting the
old DCU fanbase but it definitely
attracted a brand new DCU fanbase so
much so that only a few days before the
actual release of the movie Teen Titans
go received an Emmy nomination what
amazing timing the show got nominated
for Outstanding short form animated
program last year Teen Titans go lost
its image to adventure time
shir might turn out to be it's perfect
time to shine doesn't it make you just a
little bit proud but a silly DC show
like this one actually made it as far as
getting an Emmy nomination if the show
manages to win an Emmy it would really
affect the movie success in the most
positive way possible we're telling you
this is the best possible timing for the
Teen Titans go movie and for keeping all
of our 20 fingers crossed for this one
what do you think the Teen Titans go
deserve that Emmy nomination or do you
think they'll get beat by another
Cartoon Network show once again come let
us know in the comments Nicolas Cage
speaking of meta this is as meta as it
can get in the DC Universe if you
haven't heard about Nicolas Cage and his
90s campaign to play Superman you're
missing out if everything turned out the
way he wanted to back in the day Nicolas
Cage would have played Superman in a Tim
Burton movie called Superman lives it
was the role of his dreams and he didn't
hold back to express that but
unfortunately things just didn't work
out when it came to production time and
a bunch of other drama a Nicholas Cage
never got to live his dreams
Nicholas even said that the movie him
and Tim would have made would have been
more powerful than any other Superman
movies that ever existed it would have
been the Superman movie that's a bold
statement but hey we kind of believe it
and more than 20 years later Nicholas
finally got the opportunity you'll be
seeing him playing Superman in Teen
Titans go to the movies you better cheer
extra hard for the man that finally made
his dreams come true so many years later
this is one of those chase your dreams
feel-good stories we just needed to hear
today
well done Nic Cage Stan Lee we're
telling you although this is a cartoon
an animated movie made for kids there
are tons of cameos that will be
appreciated by old school fans Stan Lee
is a superhero of the Marvel world known
to redesign superheroes and give them
flawed humanity because of his iconic
status he's had cameos in pretty much
every Marvel movie there is but he's
never actually done a new work for DC
Comics Marvel fans love to keep Stanley
to themselves but it looks like this
will come to an end with Teen Titans go
movie that's right Stan Lee makes an
appearance and it's as meta as it can
possibly get we're telling you adult
humor is strong
this one in the actual cameo Stan even
realizes that he's not in the Marvel
movie and it's not even the only cameo
seriously you'll just need to watch the
movie for this one Stan Lee has had
plenty of cameos and other movies but
this might just be a monumental moment
for DC you we're telling you this movie
is the kid Deadpool and it doesn't even
stop there stay tuned because there are
a lot more truths you never ever got to
hear before the love for Will Arnett
okay you probably heard that Teen Titans
go isn't exactly a popular show for old
schools these 2.you fans but there's one
thing even old school fans will
appreciate and that is Will Arnett
Will's playing Slade on Teen Titans go
and fans are really excited about it
mainly because most remember will as
Batman in the lego movie which will also
get its sequel in 2019 Predators seem
really happy with will appearing and
Teen Titans go praising the movies
actual potential by having this cast
some fans even stated that they're not
all that crazy about Teen Titans go but
knowing that will is in the movie makes
them want to see it that's the power of
Will Arnett combined with subtle cameos
from Stan Lee and of course Nicolas Cage
finally getting his moment of glory many
fans are admitting that they're pretty
stoked to see Teen Titans go to the
movies if you want to see more of Will
Arnett we definitely recommend watching
any of his previous Batman roles
it seems odd that he's playing Slade in
this one doesn't it there's a reason
he's so beloved and we have a feeling
she'll be equally as awesome as Slade
and we absolutely can't wait to see him
DCU tributes the entire movie is
basically a tribute to the DC Universe
the basic plot consists of the gang
making a superhero movie because they
believe that's the only way they can be
recognized as real heroes but even the
DC humor is way above what you'd
normally see in Teen Titans go
for example they even make fun of Green
Lantern's 2011 movie which got one of
the worst reviews ever and a Rotten
Tomatoes score of 26 percent Wonderwoman
notes that she's totally aware it took
way too long for her to get her own
movie and we totally agree the Teen
Titans go gang also gets to visit the
Warner Brothers Studio where they see
Batman and Superman filming their sequel
there's a scene which is a tribute to
dawn of Jeff
we're Batman and Superman learned that
their moms have the same name but not
their dads you can also find several
other moments that actually make fun of
the DCU as well as give tribute wherever
that's needed although the original show
definitely comes with plenty of twisted
humor there's just something very meta
about the whole DC you approach in Teen
Titans go to the movies toilet humor but
because Teen Titans go kids go
completely out of their skin their movie
also has to feature some of the most
inappropriate and immature humor no
literally there's toilet humor in the
movie it has a literal joke about a fake
toilet that according to IGN com goes on
for way too long
any DCU fans can tell you that the
inappropriate jokes are partially why
they struggle to get on board with the
show and unfortunately the movie still
has that same humor it's one of those
things you really have to be in the mood
to hear otherwise it just won't be
entertaining and ign.com review states
that the amount of toilet humor might
quite possibly test your patience
so although the movie does have a lot of
novelty and tributes that old school
fans will appreciate it sticks to the
original Teen Titans go brand IGN has
stated that the movie is bunkers but in
the best way possible it's perfect for
fans of the series as well as comic book
fans in need of some serious nostalgia
seriously we can't tell you how excited
we are about Nic Cage to be in this
movie box-office success
Teen Titans go to the movies had a
predicted box-office success before it
even officially hit the theaters it
could be this is the result of the
combination of everything we've talked
about in today's video so what's the
predicted box-office success well as of
a few days before the movie's release
its tracking between 14 and 19 million
dollars for its opening weekend which is
pretty impressive it might still seem
far away from the box office opening
weekend success of something like the
lego movie but it's still impressive for
a show that isn't exactly loved by
old-school DCU fans and the Emmy Awards
are scheduled on the 17th of September
2018 we have a feeling the entire Teen
Titans go franchise will be positively
affected if they actually win it's an
exciting time for Teen Titans go overall
but the nomination itself could
definitely
increase the popularity of the movie of
course this popularity might also come
because of the excellent cast list and
all other cameos we've already talked
about today speaking of cast list check
out who's actually in the movie all your
fave actors
truth be told Teen Titans go to the
movies has some of the most amazing cast
ever all main Teen Titans go cast are
reprising their roles in this movie but
we're so excited to see some of the new
fresh faces - along with Nicolas Cage
Will Arnett and Stan Lee will also get
to see Kristen Belfort rain Jade Wilson
you might know Kristen from frozen where
she played Anna or shows like Veronica
Mars and Gossip Girl the adorably
hilarious actress gladly accepted this
role and worked with the directors to
make sure she portrays Jade Wilson as
the powerful character she is Wonder
Woman also makes an appearance in this
movie and she'll be portrayed by the one
and only Halsey the iconic voice-over
artist Tara Strong will return as the
voice of Raven and Greg Cipes will
return as Beast Boy Scott men Ville will
return as Robin but we'll also get to
see Jimmy Kimmel play Batman yep that
means Jimmy Kimmel and Nicolas Cage will
get in the fight as their characters how
bizarre is that having Kristen Bell
Jimmy Kimmel and Howze all in the same
movie seems like a truly unexpected
surprise Kristen Bell said that the
movie is totally an over-the-top action
comedy but we have a feeling this cast
will make it even better it might just
be a dream cast every animated movie
should have surprisingly good reviews
seriously in case you don't know by now
DCU fans are usually not fans of Teen
Titans go they have their own reasons
behind this and we've already talked
about some of them in this video many
are also unhappy that Teen Titans go
took over Cartoon Network schedules and
put Steven universe on the back burner
as a result but surprisingly Teen Titans
go to the movies have pretty good
reviews as of July 22nd 2018 critics
that got to see the movie before it was
officially released gave it a 100% score
on Rotten Tomatoes top critics have
praised its meta humor and added that
the movie is even more enjoyable than
grown-up superhero blockbusters another
added that the movie is /
for anyone who just can help but I roll
at the seriousness of super-heroes
it appears to be an ideal family movie
with a little something for everyone
whether you like superheroes nostalgia
over-the-top seats of humor or DCU
Easter eggs
it looks like Teen Titans go won't be as
negatively accepted as it's Cartoon
Network show what do you think will you
go see Teen Titans go to the movies what
are you most excited about
come let us know in the comments and
that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]